it's an unusual form of delivery service
and there are plenty of people waiting
for the supplies inside this vehicle at
a roadside stop in Lisbon a queue is
formed and the hatch on the van is
lowered small cups pass through the
opening but there's no ward Andry drink
inside the liquid is the heroin
substitute methadone now we have to
drink our own water because of
coronavirus you know the methadone is
mixed with water to dilute the bitter
taste the daily dose allowing drug users
to handle their addiction safely the
last two maybe five months for the first
time I almost don't use heroin it wasn't
necessary to use Aaron because I have
met it on the methadone delivery is a
part of a radical drug strategy in
Portugal which saw the country
decriminalized personal possession and
consumption of drugs in 2001 coupled
with the treatment and harm reduction
approach which has had benefits for
society the addicts here tell us they no
longer commit crime to buy drugs on the
streets when I start the program I
stopped still was the first thing we're
not done with stopped still straight
away support met alone no passport no
method on the recent weeks have
presented huge challenges for the team
operating this service hundreds more
people have been demanding methadone
daily since the covert outbreak street
supplies of heroin and other drugs have
dried up no plane no ships no cars
means no drugs we had a lot of people
coming to us to search for help the team
was kept on operating but with fewer
people on board the vehicles continuing
to treat addiction as a health and
social issue the man regarded as one of
the main architects of Portugal's
approach insists it works
cutting needle use and associated
infections we can say for instance in
terms of the HIV sprayer we had a
dramatic drop during the 90s we used at
least one overdoses that died
that means 360 something nowadays we are
around 50 40 many here still shaun
methadone in favor of the real thing and
in response this year portugal
introduced arguably its most
controversial service yet this is the
first and for now only van where people
can inject drugs with clean needles
under medical supervision usually heroin
crack cocaine or in this man's case
benzodiazepines prevention of bacterial
infection viral infection HIV hepatitis
C B and I think we are helping them to
have a safer consume
the Portuguese approach which has had
broad political backing for two decades
has garnered international attention
other nations exploring whether there
are lessons to be learned here which
could work at home
Michelle Clifford Sky News Lisbon
Portugal